le rachat de la filière nucléaire de
general electric par edf celle épilogue
du moins on l'espère d'un dossier vieux
de plusieurs années et qui entachent
sérieusement le bilan des manuels mâcon
et de fait le président de la république
n'a pas encore posé le pied à belfort
que déjà les critiques fusent emmanuel
macron me fait penser à un pyromane qui
aurait passé dix années a allumé au
lance-flammes des foyers un peu partout
et qui se met très tardivement en scène
comme un activiste forestier chez deux
modules de bluettes une motte de terre
un arbre et une pelle à la main macron
ira jeudi à belfort pour célébrer le
rachat par edf des turbines arabelle
qu'il avait lui-même bradé à general
electric dans l'immense camp d'al alstom
on ne peut rien macron a passé son temps
à brader notre industrie justice sera
faite macron compte célébrer avec
tambours et trompettes le rachat de ce
qu'il a bradé depuis general electric à
supprimer 3000 emplois nous n'avons pas
besoin de macron pour réparer ces dégâts
la branche énergies marines d'alstom
cédés à general electric doit être
nationalisées et les amendes payées
comptant et oui la vente de la branche
énergie d'alstom et notamment des
turbines arabes elles qui vont avec
c'est bien à l'actuel chef de l'état
qu'on la doit emmanuel macron avait
supervisé le dossier lorsqu'il était
secrétaire général adjoint de l'elysée
avant d'autoriser la vente fin 2014
alors qu'il était ministre de l'économie
les turbines à vapeur arabelle on les
retrouve dans nos centrales nucléaires
dont nous sous marins ou encore dans le
porte avions charles de gaulle d'où les
réticences de l'époque a laissé passer
cette technologie sous pavillon
américain mais bercy s'était voulu
rassurant emmanuel mâcon s'est assurée
avec vigilance que les intérêts de
l'état la pérennité de la filière
nucléaire et la sécurisation de
l'approvisionnement énergétique de la
france sont pleinement pris en compte
dans cette opération en 2016 après le
rachat de general electric a suspendu le
travail de ses équipes de maintenance
dans les centrales pour forcer edf à
revoir le contrat d'entretien des
réacteurs et réduire la responsabilité
financière du groupe américain en cas
d'incident comme sauvegarde de la
souveraineté on a fait mieux mais
surtout general electric s'est assis
sans vergogne sur ses promesses
d'emplois aucun des 1000 postes prévues
n'aient vu le jour à la place ce sont
5000 personnes qui ont perdu leur
travail depuis la session d'alstom en
prenant en compte la sous traitance dont
1200 à belfort enfin avec l'arrestation
dans les cadres dirigeants d'alstom aux
états unis en 2013 la vente du fleuron
français est depuis cité comme l'un des
exemples les plus frappants de la guerre
économique que les états unis livre même
à leurs alliés via l'extraterritorialité
du droit américain tout ça pour que
finalement general electric rendent le
bébé sept ans plus tard contre quelques
centaines de millions de dollars que va
devoir payer des faits puisque c'est
elle qui récupère l'ancienne branche
dalston un peu contre son gré d'ailleurs
une intégration purement et simplement
dans edf comme le souhaite le
gouvernement n'est pas une solution edf
n'a jamais construit deux turbines ce
n'est pas un industriel sans compter que
l'électricien est déjà très endetté mais
qu'importe la stratégie énergétique du
gouvernement passe par le nucléaire en
nucléaire souverain qui plus est depuis
que l'exécutif s'est rendu compte des
dégâts que peut occasionner une crise de
l'approvisionnement en énergie comme
celle que nous vivons actuellement
personne n'avait vu venir la gravité de
cette crise énergétique a déclaré ce
mardi bruno le maire décidément entre ça
et la crise du coc vide l'anticipation
n'aura pas été le point fort des manuels
macron c'est sans doute ce qui le
contraint à venir réparer ce jeudi à
belfort les erreurs commises il ya sept
ans